I'm from res - Peter Pan welcome back to
five nights of Freddy's night for how
many nights are there seven maybe that's
a yes in Swedish language should we just
do that that'd be great thank you want a
sandwich I should be a thing let's make
that a thing all right well let's listen
to the phone column this is nothing
Victoza
hell better burn on [ __ ] off are you
burping at me
I never burped at you alright mmm ago
every Hagee's except case you bros told
me put the volume up more that makes it
scarier this half [ __ ] [ __ ] again
what am i doing it laughs my heart it
hurts I think I'm I am I sitting down to
play the game now alright well that was
a great fun Edgar what are you doing huh
champagne
you want to make out with me senpai
you know you can't make out with me you
little [ __ ] I'm not a [ __ ] like you
were turn up the volume they said it
won't be fun they said suck my ass I
said oh he is there I forgot about the
stupid sign so many animatronics how was
a man gonna live in a world with this
animatronics every way Oh
pac-man wocka wocka tsamina mina eh eh
waka waka waka hey no so many - I mean
Zarina [ __ ] off I know you're there mr.
wolf what does the Fox say that's what
it says in this game sorry yeah I'm not
talking to you again I'm talking to some
pie no wait you're something [ __ ] it I
don't know I love video games because
they [ __ ] my ears shut up oh god I hear
them in events oh [ __ ] it's balloon ass
oh god alright alright he's there what
do i do then oh god oh god oh god it's
running out I can't don't kill me don't
kill me - Kimmy - Kimmy I feelings I
have feelings [ __ ] off [ __ ] off I have
feelings [ __ ] off I have a lakh [ __ ] me
senpai senpai do not [ __ ] [ __ ] in my
ass out I think it'd I think that was a
close one for ChaCha's animal tea closer
ties pritchett Oh Chaz locos tortoise
[ __ ] up what one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
either Andrew [ __ ] my ass [ __ ] my ass
thinking about how dogs are born and
playing this game and I am playing happy
flappy bird on my cellphone you want you
want a challenge I you think I don't
have a multitask I was born doing this
[ __ ] baby ducks are born through eggs
see I got this [ __ ] [ __ ] I heard an
event get get it get out get out why is
that all you got for me for all kind of
balloon ass
god I hate the balloonist
but Luna is my worst enemy in the blue
flappy bird oh man a lot flappy bird
[ __ ] my ass bird that's [ __ ]
interesting and now oh I just came up
with a great idea for an intervention
how about if instead of a sandwich maker
that that works underwater how about
that that came to me just just now while
lamb [ __ ] well it while I'm or [ __ ] no
okay well you've done it now yo shut up
don't hurt me I have feelings no it's a
balloon ass damn it ah and what about a
teddy bear that works in space 4 space
kids in the future [ __ ] alright he's
here don't hurt me I have feelings can I
can like Emma chemicai meant to me
all right I missed I'm assuming that
means he's gone
suck my ass senpai gotta gotta gotta
gotta gotta gotta get that not the
Balloon Boy
mm please [ __ ] me every [ __ ] time god
I hate the bloom boy
but little boy can suck my ass Balloon
Boy is way worse enemy
oh [ __ ] oh god I'm what do I do about
you then what the [ __ ] am I supposed to
do but if you have enough feet kid my
posture yah oh yeah the mask right damn
it
so scared it's so scary when you know
it's coming so why exactly can I put on
the mask all the time like wouldn't that
salt oh yes coz some of the animatronics
wants to destroy the day old ones I like
how are they decorated the place
can we talk about how chic and wants to
be a prostitute baby if you gave it to
me I gave it to you I know what you want
senpai suck my ass ah dammit we're gonna
do it Bros together
show me Oh brofist show me your bro
first we'll order so great okay hey man
how you doing
don't I'm sorry about before jesus
[ __ ] christ
suck my ass so [ __ ] hard what did
this game expect from me oh great no I
missed him
why do they all want to kill me I'm such
a nice person
have you even tried it make out with me
no then don't talk to me damn it let me
use the [ __ ] [ __ ] go away damn it
Belen boys here
[ __ ] off Balloon Boy no one likes you
know what I said whenever said oh I love
that Balloon Boy no no one said sad [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm dead
nope I'm alive it's good to be your life
it's good to be alive haha [ __ ] me in
the ass
haha [ __ ] it's not even 2 a.m. 2 a.m.
waking up in the morning replica but I
can [ __ ] my ass gotta have my bowl gotta
have my cereal seeing everything I may
take anything out everybody's actually
gotta get down to the bush tube gotta
get my big ass our feelings came out of
me and they came out hard alright 3 M
suck my ass this is when it started to
get interesting alright I wish I could
just skip here every time I died cuz I
don't know it's a lot of [ __ ] I don't
like a lot of [ __ ] come on he's gonna
[ __ ] me god oh I know what likes yo you
look like [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] damn it
the red events again Batman alright
alright so if he comes up if he comes up
if he comes up I'm gonna [ __ ] a truck I
swear to god I'm gonna [ __ ] truck
alright he's sunk you're not gonna come
up you're not gonna do it you're not
gonna do it what oh maybe I need to
blink um here go away no one likes you
you sound like [ __ ] I don't know you
sound like [ __ ] [ __ ] doesn't make sound
actually it does that was a lie damn it
they're broke here now well [ __ ] just
stick out [ __ ] am I supposed to know how
to play a game
PewDiePie has to do everything go away
normal X 4m 4m pram pram for an
appointment for him we can do this we
can [ __ ] sucking ass we can [ __ ]
sucking ass go away no one likes you to
go away
oh god anyone but your balloon s and he
went back to balloon s what you gonna do
or Batman Shampoo
what you gonna buy shampoo we're doing
[ __ ] amazing bras oh my god I wish
you were here to suck my ass right now
this would be so [ __ ] good not in a
sexual way just like a friend to friend
as suckage come on come on
no not good unless you tried it nope not
gonna let you tried a no I'm not gonna
let it right don't like it that is right
now I got it as long as I don't run out
of ass fuel as long as I don't run out
of ass field as long I got all right one
of them is here oh god no all right you
switch places that's [ __ ] great what
Oh God so much [ __ ] going on I don't
know how to [ __ ] ah ah map
5 a.m. make it up in the morning gotta
be fresh good
dammit he's here hey hey no no I was so
close how I sell cluck what do you even
come even come what do you even come
from where did he even come from where
did he even come
I demand an answer I've had it written
to me at 5 a.m. and yeah where you going
you don't like my speech how are you
gonna go then take your cake take cake
to the children how about you eat my
[ __ ] cage you [ __ ] owe you one
you want some [ __ ] cake please spoil
a prank
take it alright you want some cake suck
my ass and take some cake
now you want to take [ __ ] that's right
take the kick oh god he's coming give
him the damn cake damn it Jeff last week
but lasso Henley I had it I [ __ ] had
it I [ __ ] had it
all right that was a bullish crapper and
you know it where'd he come from
not nothing no one in the vent no one in
front of me is like hey what's up it's
you thought you would actually make this
one I'll [ __ ] yo that's what happened
god dammit you Edgar you are stuck in my
headphones you pregnant little [ __ ]
sorry oh I'm sorry I'm gonna mean to
call you a pregnant [ __ ] come back
please thank you [ __ ] it
alright I live to end that part there
I'm trying I'm trying I'm trying warning
a lot from me dammit alright leave it
like four part what is it part five and
really appreciate it and I will see Bros
as always and the next one I try to not
let you down I'm sorry bro fears